he's not driven to be average he's not
driven to be good
I'm sure he's driven to be great I think
he's driven to be the best and he's not
gonna be here long
my name is on the ball I play point
guard and I'm committed to UCLA I put a
banner up that would be I don't email
work that can describe that you go down
in history forever
it was November that year that you had
actually ever since the kid you know you
ladies there's always been my team
that's my hometown history much speaks
for itself
you got a John Wooden other
championships other players they got to
the league that was on TV or something
I'm always watching a play I remember
when I was little what's the rest both
came down the middle and just straight
up dunk going to do remember that moment
just went right outside from my rim down
to my brother to come out saw one of
them jump with me and I try to do it
what was it what did the way he plays I
felt the energy when he dunked it just
something just filled in I was like I
won't be like that do when I go well
there's a lot of guys look up to their
arse all right guys look up to that's
grateful onso because he's looking up to
the right guy
Russ is special there's probably will be
a lot of similarities in their games
because Westbrook comes at you every
possession and I think Alonzo is going
to develop that as well for the first
time I think our whole staff so long
though we just knew very special talents
probably the most phenomenal passer I've
seen in high school basketball his first
guy I've ever seen make a post E from 80
feet I've never seen that the player we
looked at special players you like to
see guys that can beat you by passing
they can beat you by breaking down off
the dribble they can beat you if I'm
making shots he can do all that what Ben
get brought about Lazos how good he is
defensively he's long he's athletic he's
fast he's quick and yet he's able to
slow the game down to him to where he
can just pick you apart with his passing
so he's got a lot of uniqueness to him
and we can't wait for you bidding like I
helped you sell a go back to what they
used to be because right now they don't
really have a set point guard I don't
really have that lead
the floor now they got all the pieces
you need but at the end of the day you
gotta have a point or in order to win
and I feel like I can throw that spot